PLUS.
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
DAN BONGINO AND MARK STEYN WITH
US IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, JEFF HERRON.
JEFF?
>> THE SUSPECT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
HE'S FROM RICHMOND HILL,
ONTARIO, NORTH OF TORONTO.
HIS LINKEDIN ACCOUNT SAID HE'S A
STUDENT AT A COLLEGE HERE IN
TORONTO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CONFRONTATION WITH POLICE, WHEN
POLICE CAUGHT UP TO THE ALLEGED
SUSPECT.
IT APPEARED THAT HE MAY HAVE HAD
A GUN POINTED AT POLICE OR CELL
PHONE, THE OTHER REPORT GOING
AROUND.
OF COURSE IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME
TO GET THAT CONFIRMATION.
HE WAS EVEN SHOUTING THINGS LIKE
SHOOT ME, KILL ME.
THAT WILL NOW BE PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION AS TO WHETHER
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AT PLAY HERE.
THE CANADIAN GOVERNMENT SAID
THAT THE 28-YEAR-OLD IS NOT
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY TERRORIST
GROUP AS SUCH.